hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about a
kind of growth medium for growing
certain kinds of bacteria that's known
as McConkey occur hmm so macconkey agar
has some cool characteristics it is a
growth medium that is both selective and
differential let's talk about what that
means so first of all its selective
specifically for gram-negative bacteria
this means that it allows gram-negative
bacteria to grow while preventing the
growth of gram positive bacteria it is
also differential meaning that it allows
the distinction that that sort of it
allows one to distinguish between
different types of bacteria based on
some visual component so in the case of
macconkey agar it's differential for
enteric bacilli that ferment lactose
meaning that it includes components that
allow bacteria that ferment lactose to
look different to the naked eye than
those that do not permit the lactose
let's talk about how it does these
things so first of all how is it
selected for gram-negative bacteria well
it contains crystal violet and bile
salts and these actually inhibit the
growth of gram positive bacteria so
that's how it inhibits some bacteria
while allowing other bacteria to grow in
terms of being differential it contains
lactose which is of course sugar or a
form of sugar I should say a type of
sugar as well as the pH indicator known
as neutral red and this will change
color to pink sort of a reddish pink
color when the bacteria ferment is
lactose that's present so the media when
it's just a sterile macconkey agar plate
with nothing
on it is this yellowish color but it
contains lactose and so if you put
bacteria on it they confirm it the
lactose they ferment the lactose that
produces an acid byproducts the acid
that is produced lowers the pH and that
causes the neutral red to change to this
pink color showing you that lactose
fermentation is happening and so there
are possible that that's how you're able
to make that distinction
so if did distinguish between the non
fermenters and the fermenters and that's
what makes it differential something
else to keep in mind is that some
organisms including species that are
part of the Club CLO genus or you can
tear about your Gena's produce colonies
that are not as a new pod colonies
mucoid just meaning that they are
they're kind of wet and sticky looking
and that is due to the production of a
capsule so remember that a capsule is
sort of a sticky carbohydrate-based coat
that can be outside the south wall of
hey bacterium often this helps it hide
from the immune system so it makes it
more virulent so a capsule is considered
a very Lance factor so Klebsiella and
antara bacter are some of the types of
bacteria that can produce the mucoid
colonies looking sticky and wet because
they're using the lactose that is in
this media to produce their capsules
that's why they look like that another
is something to consider is that there
is a special type of macconkey agar
called sorbitol macconkey agar sorbitol
is a sugar alcohol so it's a type of
carbohydrate and it this this sorbitol
macconkey agar contains additional
selective components that will inhibit
the growth of certain things but allow
the growth of a specific kind of e.coli
and so this is used to isolate the
specific kind of e.coli and specifically
it isn't
hemorrhagic e.coli it's the strain is
known as o157 h7 and so these are
basically different types of Sarah logic
identifications where the strain of
e.coli has certain kinds of them surface
proteins but really what this type of
e.coli is known for is it's an entero
hemorrhagic causing like bleeding in the
gut it is a really nasty kind of food
poisoning that you can get so it's
frequently found in like contaminated
food or water and can give food
poisoning but the way that the sorbitol
macconkey agar works is it has some
various inhibitory components to inhibit
the growth of other kinds of bacteria
and then specifically mixed a sorbitol
in it which is worth a different
carbohydrate from lactose and so the
bacteria that can grow on the sorbitol
macconkey agar plate that are colorless
the don't ferment sorbitol that aren't
capable of fermenting the sorbitol those
would be the entero hemorrhagic e.coli
zero 157 h7 so this is if it's a special
formulation of the macconkey agar that
can help in the isolation of that
particular kind of nasty pathogen so now
let's talk about what a macconkey agar
plate looks like remember that initially
it's going to be kind of a faint yellow
color and it's going to be selective for
gram-negative bacteria so there's lots
of gram-negative bacteria that can grow
ecologic Klebsiella and tara backdoor
salmonella Proteus Shigella your seniya
these are all types of gram-negative
bacteria that can grow on a macconkey
agar plate now if they're Lac negative
meaning that they cannot forget lactose
then the media is going to stay its
regular yellow color so you'll have
bacterial growth but no color change if
the bacteria are like positive like
these are that means they can ferment
the lactose creating an acid that lowers
the pH causes the name fo red to turn
pink and that means that you will have
sort of where this bacterial growth is a
pink zone so the plate will turn pink
wherever you have the the lactose
fermentation happening if you're
interested in learning about other kinds
of selective and differential logger
think like mannitol salt agar or eme
auger and check out my playlist on
bacterial growth media but that's it for
today and thanks for watching biology
professor